there's a lot of rumors surrounding jim
and today he addresses some of them for
good
my dad he was out of my life from fairly
young he was arrested he was in prison
for a while he was definitely
sociopathic
i wonder what man i would be if he had
stuck around
oh i've lost count the amount of times
i've been called a cheetah me and tarny
broke up just over two years ago me and
sarah got together
as far as the world is concerned a few
months later but obviously that wasn't
it because the world only found out
me and tony broke up when we decided to
tell them
because i lost my [ __ ] the other day on
on social media so i can take hate i've
got a thick skin it doesn't it bounces
straight off i don't care this is my job
it's not
a personal reflection on me but when it
comes to somebody calling my pregnant
fiance
the names they called her and saying
that my baby should be miscarried that's
where i draw the line
some people come on this podcast and
they're cagey
sometimes they even try and bend the
truth protect their ego
dare i say it sometimes they even lie
not my next guest completely utterly
brutally honest raw unfiltered
and vulnerable he's a british celebrity
with six or seven or eight million
followers but you don't know jim you
don't know jim chapman
almost nobody does today we're talking
about success
the chronic curse of overthinking we're
talking about love breakups rumors
both of the similarities in our mindsets
we're talking about how you need to be a
contradiction
in various parts of your life if you're
going to be happy something i
didn't realize until today until this
conversation
and we're talking about child abuse
child abuse to an extent that most of us
could and should hopefully
never be able to imagine we're talking
about paralyzing
anxiety social media it's upsides and
downsides
and what all of this life stuff is
fundamentally about
unavoidably there's a lot of rumors
surrounding jim
and today he addresses some of them for
good
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the dire over ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
jim i always think the most important
place to start when i have these
conversations
is getting to know the experiences
that made you who you are today because
for me that
creates the context for everything we're
about to discuss
and a lot of the time people don't
really know those things um so
tell me about some of the experiences
when you're younger when you're in
school
um that you think have contributed to
the man you are today
okay um i guess and god is instantly
gonna sound like a sob story and it
absolutely is not this is a positive
thing
i guess the first thing that brings to
me is my dad so uh my dad was
he does bad things like he he abused my
mum um
from even before i was born i got two
older sisters who
um you know dealt with it as well i
don't think he ever turned a hand to
them
but he verbally was very i mean even i
remember that and i was super young i
remember him being
very very hurtful and very unkind and
just
bullying to my sisters i think he always
wanted boys
so my brother and i were kind of like
i've got a twin so we were like
the prodigal children i suppose um
i didn't know this because obviously i
was born into it but it's not it wasn't
until i got a little older and i'd have
like sleepovers at friends houses or i
would
just be in the presence of other people
and their parents and i'd be like wait
your house isn't
terrifying that's that's uh this is
great you know and i think
i got as i got slightly older i realized
that things weren't quite right and it
was one day uh
my brother and i were in the room next
door where we slept
my parents and we walked in and my dad
was like on top of her just
beating the [ __ ] out but basically and
my brother and i we're only tiny we must
have been like five or six tried to
pull him off but obviously he was huge
so just
pinging us away and it was a wild night
you know the police came took him away
um etc etc just kind of
he i didn't know at the time but he had
been
beating my mom and abusing her for years
but of course she was
trapped now my mom is a saint but also
she doesn't tolerate falls she's not i
think the thing about domestic abuse is
a lot of people go oh just get out of
there just get out of there
it's not it's not as simple as that she
had her kids to think of
i remember being in the car with my dad
and he would threaten to just crash the
car and kill us all he drove like a
maniac
he was drunk quite a lot my mom couldn't
just leave
with four children because he found us
we tried to leave he found us you know
so i think um that he's very much a
cautionary tale for me
um he was out of my life from fairly
young but
never fully out because he
you know was taken away by the police he
was arrested he was imprisoned for a
while
but despite the fact that we had like a
court order that he couldn't come near
he still came here all the time at one
point he
kidnapped a very strong word but at one
point he took me um
it just kind of came to the window and i
was his son you know he was my dad so i
worshipped him and i still didn't
fully understand so i remember going to
the window and saying mom's calling the
police you have to go and he just
went okay and just took me with him and
drove we're in a bloody police chase
drove like
super fast and the police had to kind of
you know stop and pull him over
um it was you know it was a very
unsettling time for a child but because
of that he was removed and
i spent most of my childhood being
brought up by my mum and my big sisters
so i wanted for nothing um i was
very well loved very well protected
super well looked after
and i think actually i often wonder and
i was having this chat with sarah the
other day because obviously we've got a
child on the way
and i was thinking i wonder what man i
would be
if he had stuck around or or if we
couldn't get away from him or whatever
it would have been
um and you know
whether he wanted to or not he taught me
a lot of lessons
um but i think mostly
cautionary lessons because my family are
bloody great
you know there's uh i've got two big
sisters i've got a mum i've got a twin
brother and i would
choose no one else on the planet to take
those roles if i had the choice they
would be the people i choose 100
um and he missed out on that because he
was
unwell i would say um he had ms and i
always remember him you being a victim
of it
in a way that my sister inherited from
it from him
and she's so positive with it
like she's not a victim she doesn't let
it be her she has times when she's tired
it gets on top of her she has a little
sob she goes to bed she recognizes the
signs though and she goes right okay
it's getting on top of me i need to rest
for a while i remember my dad just being
like
a victim of it and being like i ruined
my life he did this he used to play
football
from what i understand a fairly high-ish
level like kind of
he played for west ham not in the a team
but something
and he was like oh the ms ruined it for
me which i'm sure it did you know
there's no question with that but
life deals you cards and you
react you behave in a way that you that
you see fit
um and he
let the card's life doubt him
ruin everything i think and i think
because of that he was angry
um i also i mean i don't say this
lightly but i think he was definitely
sociopathic
he manipulated everybody and a lot
a lot of my mom didn't even know about
until we were clear from him and then
people start asking her for money
because
you know he owed it to them i mean he he
went to
prison for like armed robbery or
something like he was just you know
really bad things um so i think for me
that's kind of
the first thing my mind goes to when
someone asks me about kind of um
childhood um formulation of me but i
don't necessarily think of it as a
negative thing because actually i think
that
because he was removed from my life by
my protectors my mum my big sisters
i had a wonderful childhood you know we
didn't have any when he was around there
was more money because i think he stole
a lot of money and because he
took it you know there was two parents
earning but also he he earned it by
what nefarious means suddenly we had no
money um
and my nan had to like buy the house
that we lived in and we stayed at my
mum's best friends for
like a year or so because she took us in
because we couldn't fall anywhere else
but
i was safe and i was happy and i was
like
my mum had more capacity to be a better
mum because she wasn't constantly
running for the hills you know so
actually i think that it's a really
positive
thing um that happened because imagine
if he was still
around imagine if he was still my father
figure now at 33
i'd be a mess for one thing i think but
i'd also be
i wonder if i'd be a not a nice man and
actually i pride myself on being
decent and kind um and he missed out on
that
i read a little bit about the story as i
was doing some research on your book and
things like that and one of the most
startling
parts of all of this is how much empathy
dare i say you appear to have for this
man which i think people would find
surprising
i think you said i don't blame him for
how things happened yeah i don't i
i actually i think of myself as quite an
empathetic person
um i rarely have arguments with people
um i do with sarah obviously because we
live under the same roof um and like we
have disagreements but
your fiance yes my fiance yeah um
although not the moment because she's
pregnant so
you can do no wrong um but i do have uh
i tend
not to have like extra personal drama
because i
i do consider how it would be from
someone else's perspective and i
appreciate that yes okay i could have my
say
because i feel slighted about a thing
and i could say well you did this and it
made me feel that
but that's my feelings on an action that
they um did and they will have
equal and opposite feelings on the way i
behaved
because of their actions nobody i don't
i believe nobody will
go out of their way just to be a prick
you know they've always got
their thoughts and feelings and their
motivations and i don't think anyone's
doing it like oh that'll pissed him off
you know what i mean they're living
their life we all live in our bubble
my uh my therapist calls it the lifeboat
we all live in our lifeboat right
um but we're all in the same ocean
so depending on how good your lifeboat
is
you will weather the storm or not right
there's a storm on the ocean we're all
in it especially at the moment it's a
pandemic right we're all in the pandemic
together but
it depends on the boat you're sailing on
um and there are times when boats kind
of bump into each other or someone's in
a dinghy and you need to sort of
tie them to yours for a while and help
them get through things whatever
but i really don't feel like anybody is
purposely
um an ass it might be manipulative they
might see
a way that they can behave that will
um better them in a situation where they
go okay i'll come off better with that
and it might
it might do him no favors but you know
they're not doing it
for that reason they're doing it for
that reason they're doing it because
they want to
um have a better situation for them not
just to piss me off
so i tend not to have arguments i will
say to someone that's not cool
can you see that from my perspective um
and you and
and do you think so when you think about
your the situation with your dad
it seems like from that you you avoid
attributing blame to him
and then so i i'm questioning myself i'm
saying is that because you
understand the reasons why he was the
way he is or
um you have empathy for i have yeah i
just i think i just have empathy for
people i don't
i think there's definitely blame i think
we all we all have to own our own
actions
um but i think there are also
there are reasons behind actions i don't
think it's ever as simple as
he hit my mum just because he's
aggressive i think you have to
dig deeper like my my granddad was
so his dad not okay i remember being i
remember
going to his house and he'd be like
watching not porn but like softcore in
front of us
you know as just he was just i don't
know i don't know if he was just a bit
like
um senile at that point or or what but
you know it's not all right to do that
with young kids around
um and you see these generational cycles
right 100
yeah and i'm very proud and very happy
to have broken that cycle because you
know my i don't i don't know what his
dad was like but my granddad taught my
dad
his behavior not all of it because i
actually i actually do think there was
um
i actually do believe my dad had
sociopathic tendencies which isn't
necessarily a taught thing it's more
like a
brain function thing you know um but i
think there was definitely
something there and it didn't help
having his dad
i teach instill in him certain beliefs
and
patterns or whatever quick one starting
from the minute the lockdown is lifted
we're going to start bringing in some of
our subscribers to watch how this
podcast is produced behind the scenes
means you get to meet the guests meet
myself and see how we put all of this
together
if you want that to be you all you've
got to do hit the subscribe button
my mum is a very allowed person and
that's a huge understatement like loves
to scream in people's faces very short
temper
my dad is a certain way and as i've got
older and older i've got more
conscious that at times i feel like
myself becoming a little bit like them
in certain moments
and it scares me sometimes i think
and i think well genetically of course
i'm half of each of them
so um have you ever has it ever
concerned you in the same way
that you might have picked up some of
the unpleasant traits of either of your
parents
um is that across your mind i'm turning
into my mom my mum
my mom has unpleasant traits only in as
far as she
for example when i moved house wouldn't
stop going about parking
like that sort of thing oh you better go
pokemon i live in london you don't get
off street parking i've got a parking
permit i park around the corner that's
my life
but she's like oh you need to get a
driveway i'm like no
i don't like that's the sort of thing
she won't let it drop she's got a fact
in her mind about
um trump for example and she goes oh
trump's bad he did this thing i'm like
yeah but what about all the other things
you know so she's um that's her kind of
annoying trait
and if that's the worst i get then i'm
fine with that um as far as my dad i
don't
think i mean yeah like i say he's half
me or i'm half him i suppose
um but i think that the thing is about
my degree is in psychology right so i
know a little bit about it and i'm
always quite conscious like i know for
example there are certain genes that
will only get triggered under certain
environments
so yes all right i might well have his
gene for something but if i don't
if i'm not in an environment where it's
had to uh where it would have expressed
itself
then i might never and i also think that
there is an element of um
i guess consciousness that can override
that self-awareness
yeah self-awareness education because
therapy psychology totally yeah yeah i'm
very
um i work on and i said i hate this i
hate saying this
it sounds like really wanky but i work
on bettering myself you know i
i i know my flaws i work too much like i
forget to bring my head up and i neglect
sarah sometimes because i'm too busy
typing away or i'm too busy
in my own little world stressing about
whatever i'm stressing about
which doesn't need to happen but it does
and i i'm aware of that and that's the
sort of thing i work on
but i've never been aggressive never
been violent
um i really i do boxing quite a lot
um but it's not about the violence of it
it's about the chess of it like i really
like the
it's an intellectual sport you know you
have to be smart you have to
think about where you're positioning all
the time um and i've never
this is not i don't know if it's not in
my nature but it's something that i
won't
entertain there are times where i get
driven bonkers
by sarah or by people and i just think
oh my god i could
just like nut you right now obviously
i'm never going to yeah
because it's just every fiber in my
being is
would not allow me because i've seen the
impact i've seen
i'm six foot three i could do some real
damage um
but i just never would so i i i do get
loud sometimes if i'm
you know if we're having an argument i
would kind of just
talk louder and
i think with mister in particular is
tricky because we're both quite smart
and so when it comes to an argument
we're just trying to outsmart each other
the whole time
which makes it really frustrating
because we're both going no you're wrong
because of this
yeah and both of you are right yeah and
actually yeah there's truth in both
um for sure um but it's really hard to
see that when you've got your blood up
you know what i mean but
i totally think that there's no there's
i've got
i like to think i've got the best bits
of my mum um
and if there is any kindness in my dad
and i remember moments i don't i don't
have loads of memories of him and
90 of them are negative and scary but
there are moments i remember him
sitting down with me and reading there
was a magazine i forget what it was
called but
you used to get like um a little bit of
a figure
every time and you'd make the figure and
it was like something to do with bugs
and we made a big spider 12 quid per
magazine basically yeah really really
overpriced but i remember him
um he would read it with me from cover
to cover and we'd put the bug together
now
there would end up being six issues um
that we didn't get done and we'd have to
do them in one go because he wasn't
around because he was gone doing
whatever he was doing and
um he would let me down a lot but i
remember doing them
and i remember loving that time with him
um
what kind of dad do you want to become
because you've got a kid on the way now
congrats again
yeah thanks um it's really hard to say
this because i know that
every first time prospective parent goes
oh i'm going to be the best dad
and actually you know invariably will
all [ __ ] up at some point right
it's gonna happen um i just i think
for me if i can have a child and if i
can instill in them
the waste of time in anxiety like that
just the the just the sheer
nonsense of it like i i really want them
to understand
that worrying does nothing you know yes
all right we can be stressed about
things there are times when
life is hard and things
there's challenges to overcome but you
overcome those challenges when they
present themselves
there's no my therapist once said to me
when you worry you rob yourself twice
right because the first time around
you're
overwhelmingly thinking about nothing
but a potential problem which may never
ear its head
if it doesn't ruin its head then you've
wasted time worrying about it if it does
ruin its head then you're forced into
action because you can't stay in that
situation
so why stress about something that's
never gonna happen or you know
something that you will solve if it does
happen so i really want
my child to understand just be content
i think um and to know that
both me and sarah and all of our
families so my my siblings my mum
sarah siblings and her parents will
always be there to
help you know i think that if i can do
that then i'll have done
a good job um i want to be patient it's
in my nature i'm a very patient person
but i also know that i'll be tested so
when i do snap
i snap quite quite loudly so
i want to be calm i want to be patient i
want to be
soft and considerate
and again empathetic because the thing
about kids is i i really appreciate is
they get
frustrated because they're obviously
told what to do by their parents they
can't
necessarily verbalize or especially
don't have the communication ability to
say
no that's not what i want you know they
have to appreciate that obviously what i
want overrules it for the most part
because
safety or whatever sure but i think they
i also need to appreciate that they'll
be frustrated because they can't
communicate effectively why they feel
pissed off because i said no um and that
will often come out in like
tantrums or whatever so and they won't
understand daddy's world and why
right when they're trying to get your
attention they don't know you're on a
zoom core pitching something for example
just like daddy won't play with me you
know so
it's interesting i also want to make
sure i'm around enough my job totally
allows that
like i have time i can work as little as
much as i want that's that's the beauty
of my job obviously i work less i earn
less but
you know i can make those sacrifices i
don't at the moment that's my problem i
work
constantly because i like what i do and
because of the constant
it's anxiety i'm constantly worried
about if i take my foot off the gas what
happens next
i find that fascinating but i picked up
on that before we started recording
right because every time we talked about
your screenplays
or other things you're working on you
would then end the sentence with
but i might lose it all right and i i
don't resonate like that i found that
interesting because it's not how i end
my sentences right
but it was it was like you would tell me
something and then
you would also then almost caveat it at
the end with there is a chance i might
not
i might not get it or i might lose it
all yeah and i i
i find it particularly because i don't
think in that way right so where does
that come from in you this
my mum right uh 100 again she's
wonderful she
has like a like an ethos it's not saying
it's an ethos which is like
a day doing nothing's a day wasted um
she can't relax i can't relax as a
consequence
um if i'm sitting there just chilling
even if i'm watching a film which
for me i consider as research because i
write films right if i'm watching
something i'm like oh okay i see what
they're doing there
and it's like i don't watch them
passively i'm constantly thinking about
them
um but even if i'm sitting there and
watching a film i'm like oh i shouldn't
be doing it it's
9 p.m right it's the evening and i'm
supposed to be relaxing and i'm
sitting there and i shouldn't be doing
this i shouldn't be doing this that's my
biggest what's your brain saying in that
moment it's telling me off
it's it's going dude you need to be you
can't just be sitting here watching you
need to be doing you need
working and making what if this all goes
wrong how are you going to earn the
money how are you going to afford to
look after your child and
pay the mortgage and you know all that
stuff a lot of people will resonate with
that
for sure um and you've addressed it in
therapy
yeah what have you learned i learned
that i do it
yeah which a lot of people don't even
know right that self-awareness of
knowing that it's a problem you have
and and it's taking me i've been seeing
uh my therapist for christ
six seven years something like that how
often uh it varies if i'm going through
a moment
then more often at the moment like once
every six weeks because i'm pretty chill
um but it's taken her
most of our time together just to crack
that and
she said you know with me it's my
biggest
um strength and also my biggest flaw it
just depends on where it is on the dial
like if i've got that at seven
it's great because i'm motivated and i'm
enjoying my work and i'm
loving it and i'm sitting there god i'm
really good at this you know and i'm
typing away or doing whatever i'm doing
if it's an eight or nine it's torture
paralyzed or
yeah often paralyzed often paralyzed
ironically
into doing nothing because i'm so busy
stressing
about getting it done i don't get it
done
because i've got no brain space because
it's too busy whizzing around in my head
going get it done get it done get it
done
um so there's a point where it's sort of
really um
ironically kind of just it's the
antithesis of what it's designed for
yeah
and i think i i think i get a lot of
that from my dad because i remember
being young
knowing that it was easier to be busy
and keep myself
separate so i used to draw or i'd be
like this be really arty um
yeah out of harm's way and so you would
just draw in the corner because you felt
safe if he
if you were busy and he wasn't you know
i wasn't in his in his eyeline i
couldn't
be chastised or it was safer i think my
dad he was very unpredictable
so which is terrifying for a kid right
because you don't know if you're going
to get love or you're going to get
punishment
for the same action um so i always spend
most of my time
just kind of getting on with stuff and
because of that i've developed a real
independence um a real creativity
but if it's turned up too high it's
crippling
whereas if it's a good number um then
it's what's got me to where i am i
100 would not be here without that
because i just wouldn't work as hard as
i do
um but i don't need to work as hard as i
do
you know human beings have a couple of
things they need to do they need to
sleep
they need to eat they have the option of
procreating
that's kind of it right what else is
there the rest of it is just made up
right the rest of it is just made up
[ __ ] that we've given ourselves to do
society has told us that in order to be
a complete person we need to
and it's climb right totally and it's
bloody stressful it's
it's it's debilitating sometimes so when
i have that turned up too high i end up
doing nothing
but i worry myself and sarah's like
where have you gone like i just
disappear and i don't talk i don't like
i haven't been like this for a while
because i'm pretty good at recognizing
the signs and i know
to take my foot off the gas a bit
because of you know all the therapy i've
had but
yeah it's it's the bloody worst what has
helped you
um therapy yeah absolutely that being
aware of it
there's a point i always say this
because i've actually a couple of my
best mates
have i don't know a guy that's my age
that doesn't need it by the way
um so a couple of my best mates i've put
them in touch with therapists or sort of
said something you know i think you
should see someone
and actually we're really open and
honest with each other we're constantly
looking out if one of us is quiet on the
group chat we'll go dude you all right
you've been a bit quiet
um i said to him at the time i was like
there's a really tough point with
therapy where you start seeing someone
at first you're really resistant and
you're like no i'm fine what are you
talking about
but when they point things out to you
like [ __ ] i'm not fine
but you're aware of doing it but you
have no tools in place
of how to stop doing it or how to at
least challenge it so you're just
punishing yourself
doing it like i remember going through
that stage for a long time going i hate
that i'm failing i hate that i'm still
stressing out about
being like working constantly or not
working constantly or whatever it is i
hate that i'm doing it to myself
but i can't stop and you feel a bit like
a junkie you know in a way that you're
like
you know it's wrong you know you
shouldn't be doing it but you can't you
can't not
um and actually it takes a while to
learn
the techniques you know mine is as
simple as
it's it's painful that i have to go
right stop just don't do it
take a step away from your laptop step
away from your camera do whatever it is
you're doing
have five minutes if you feel better
after five minutes go back to it if not
then take the rest of the day off
um and that's what i have to do i need
to be
sarah needs to keep me in check quite a
lot because if i
sometimes it sneaks up on me and i'm
kind of like at stage four before i even
realized it i'm like [ __ ] i'm in too
deep
um so she's often like dude come back um
and that's really helpful it's hard
though because you don't want to be told
by someone that
you're not performing the way you should
you know what i mean actually something
that matters right
right it's totally especially when it's
you're already your weakness
um but you need to be
like i actually really like criticism so
it's good for me like if
you know if i send someone some work or
something and they go oh okay
as long as it's constructive you know
they go okay i see what you're doing
here don't like that that
that's not great i thrive on that
because i'm back in there and i'm you
know
so i think having other
third parties be like you're not doing
right right now um and that's something
that i really
want to be totally aware of when it
comes to my child because i don't want
to be an absent father i don't want to
be a dad that's
always going no no no i'm just not my
laptop come back to me five minutes i
want to be able to
obviously i have to work you know we
will have a living but i want to be able
to
have my kid with me and be present you
know and not them
think that they're sort of auxiliary or
like an afterthought or
just an addition i want them to know
that they are the center of my universe
you know
i say this every week but i'm gonna say
it again um
it is a tremendous pleasure to have a
podcast sponsor
that a you've used for maybe three years
people ask me as well they say how many
heels do you drink a day
the answer is probably about two
sometimes two and a half
um but a podcast points that you
genuinely believe can help people
change their life for the better um
watching the team at huel
argue with each other and be so
uncompromising about the ingredients
that go into this bottle or the bags or
the bars all the
hot and savory has only strengthened
my evangelism for this brand watching
the founder julian and the ceo james
insist that only the best ingredients go
in here
and be so scientifically precise about
what goes in this bottle and in the bars
and in the bags
has only made me love this more because
i know they've got my back
and i wish all of you could be in those
boardrooms that i've been in and watch
them
fight for your and my health
um via this product so professionally
we talked a little bit about your work
there one of the things that uh that
you've said is
you don't like being called like an
influencer like a youtuber
uh i think it's really reductive yeah um
and i think that actually if you look
you know if you just weigh up the
quantity of work i do
it's only about less than 50 i'd say
um unfortunately i don't get paid for
the other stuff yeah
so yeah i mean get paid for youtube at
the start absolutely yeah totally
um but i do lots of other stuff i
appreciate that
i communicate that other stuff online
via my social media
i just think that influencer is for one
thing's an ugly word
because it implies that you are um
utilizing influence over someone
whereas actually i just share the stuff
i like even if it's an ad even if
if it's um i'm working with a brand i'm
not going to work with a brand that i
don't want to talk about right so
it's i'm talking about things that i'm
actually enjoying or passionate about or
whatever it may be and i don't
see that as exerting influence i see
that as
sharing joy or even if it's just sharing
good tips or whatever it may be i see
that as
a very different thing and i i also have
a thing and i've mentioned this a few
times as
there was a void in um social media
where myself and my contemporaries all
started around the same time
did it for fun did it for love did it
for adventure we had no idea it was
going to go anywhere and
when it started to we were like oh my
god and genuinely i look back at it and
i was such
nostalgia i don't miss it but i love
that i was
part of it you know because it was such
a cool journey to moment in history as
well yeah totally absolutely was you
know and we sold out these venues and we
were you know we had screaming fans it
felt like being in a small version of
one direction you know
um it was wild and just so much fun do
you miss that
no i loved it at the time when i was in
my early twenties
every young person and i saw some of
those clips of your meetups in like
parks and stuff right
and i've never seen a line that long in
my lifetime yeah it's wild but like
like a thousand meters i don't even know
how many meters that is of
people right four like four deep
in like this massive line just screaming
and crying at times it's really hard to
put into words i tried explaining it to
sarah when we first met because
obviously
videos yeah it's really hard and if i
get stopped on the street now by someone
she's like what yeah but she's also like
oh they didn't scream or cry i'm like
yeah you don't get it
used to be yeah um but what my point was
is that like
everyone thinks especially young people
especially young men
well all young people would love to be
that guy and you're telling me you don't
miss it
no i loved it at the time don't get me
wrong it was great but the novelty soon
wears off because
it got to the point where you couldn't i
couldn't take public transport
i couldn't walk to the shops um
you know and it sounds like i'm really
exaggerating but actually at the time it
really was that just
i would even now if i'm walking along
the street and i see a group of
teenagers i'm like oh [ __ ]
here we go it's not teenagers anymore
they're all in their 20s but i'm so
conditioned to being aware of
teenagers now that i'm like oh my god oh
my god they're going to come for me and
they're going to
like scream and cry and it's i don't how
is this played with your anxiety though
that's not that's not what sets me off
so that's fine um
i've always got time for it if people
stop and want to have a conversation as
long as i
physically have time for it i'm not
rushing i'll always stop and have a chat
you know i've got
i'm i'm i'm really gracious in that i
appreciate that
without those people i wouldn't be in
the position i'm in i don't feel like i
owe them anything because at the same
time i provided the content they wanted
to watch
but it's definitely like almost like a
transaction right i wouldn't be there
without them they wouldn't
a lot of them have said like when i had
amounts that i was pregnant sarah was
pregnant
a lot of them sort of said oh my god i
can't believe you you like bought me up
because a lot of these teenagers watched
my content and my contemporaries content
um like shay carl as well right totally
because
because they they loved like watching us
and we were
role models for them i suppose you know
and that's a really wonderful
thing to be part of and do i say you
were idyllic in a way that
it often with with the shape the
shaytards and
shaykhal and his family right i didn't
have a perfect family like that so it
was it gave
you felt like you were part of that yeah
i think that and also the friendships
with
the others it was very identical but it
genuinely was that was our life at the
time it was just pure fun
and like there was no stress we were
young so we had no like
um no responsibilities no mortgages no
no no like other things to worry about
other than just like
going out there and having a blast and
we just got to
document that and share it no i
accept nostalgic i'm really happy i had
was part of it but i don't miss it
because
i'm 33 i don't want 14 year old girls
pawning over me or you know what i mean
or just kind of like
desperately trying i remember one time
being on the tube and this young girl
just burst into tears
and her dad looked at me and thought i
was like would you blame him you know
i was like i'm all right i'm on the
internet which didn't help because he's
just being on either he's like doing
what
um so yeah i don't i don't miss it
uh because it's actually really invasive
and like i say i don't care about the
notoriety it was really lovely to be
that person for some people um and to
have
even then it was big numbers it was
still fairly underground
it hadn't really reached mainstream it
was just online right so
although it was lots of people it was of
certain sort of
sector of society it wasn't like
older men it wasn't you know it was just
teenagers basically um
and it was yeah i'd say it was a real
blast but i don't miss it i feel like
actually i grew out of it fairly rapidly
the thing about it being teenagers is
that no one can obsess like teenagers
so they would be desperate for the photo
the selfie the
um they'd scream and cry and go
ballistic and actually but i'm really
anti-climactic
i'm just i'm some dude i'm really i'll
often just go i'm really sorry that it's
me
um so yeah i'm very like i say i'm very
grateful for it
and i love that i've got those memories
and i love that i've made those friends
um but yeah i don't miss it who's jim
now then
so that's if that's old jim and that's
your say your first chapter
what is that what is your second chapter
i feel like i've had so many chapters
actually i feel like i've
evolved the beauty of my job right is
i'm allowed to do that i'm allowed to
evolve
when it's forced it can be really ugly
and i think that's how a lot of people
lose their following um partly it's
it's entropy you know people grow up and
they move on they do other things but
algorithms algorithms all that but i
think mostly it's just
people force it to try to get traffic
and views and actually my life has just
as it's changed i've grown up with it
and i've been
i've accepted that change okay like for
example i'm really i'm really hoping i
turn into a silver fox i'm
looking forward to ageing gracefully you
know what i mean and i think that
that's kind of my my my role on social
media i'm not pretending to
talk to young people anymore i'm not
pretending to be the cool guy
and like you know i'm i appreciate that
i'm
i'm getting older my life's changed my
interests have changed my
career has changed and i share that with
people as opposed to
desperately trying to still impress
a young an audience that aren't right
for me i i speak to a lot of youtubers
and we used to sign a couple
and there was this really interesting
moment where that first wave of youtuber
because of algorithm changes i think
predominantly algorithm changes what
they were doing then just stopped
working right the views went down
and i swear to god i witnessed a form of
depression
and existential crisis right from these
youtubers who
suddenly were like what the [ __ ] has
happened what do i do with my life now
because their whole identity from
whether it was like 16 years old to 22
was doing this one thing they never
really understood work right and it's
funny because i've never really talked
about this before but one of the
youtubers we signed
you'll know his name maybe 18 at the
time and i we remember calling him and
offering him 20 grand just to show up to
a place
and he's like nah right i'm like just
show up to the he's like
nice just can't be bothered like and he
had developed that sense of like
complacency about his career and how you
make money and how easy it is
and then when [ __ ] changes i'm saying he
can't make
any money anymore and and he's spiraled
down because i think
life taught him that money and life was
super easy the algorithm changes and now
he's like [ __ ]
and he has to go work at tesco that's
something that i really
can't tolerate in this industry it's
when people have that attitude
like i'm where i am um because i'm good
to work with
as much as the numbers and as much as
everything else i've stayed the test of
time because i
am honest and decent with my audience
and i respect my audience and i don't
take the piece and don't take it for
granted
but also if i am offered a job i turn up
on time i say my places and thank yous
i get a lot of repeat work because i'm
good to work with and i pride myself on
that and i
have no i have so little tolerance for
ego
like all of us if we're on set shooting
a thing whether it's
whether you're the runner or the
director or you're me doing the bit to
camera
or you're the guy going to get coffee
we're all just want to do our job and
enjoy what we're doing and then go home
at the end of the day and say oh that
was nice
you know we don't there's no space for
any of that and i think it's
particularly bad in this industry right
more so than the other because when it
comes to
musicians or actors or whatever
they are there's so many people around
them right who are
um looking after them and who are saying
no
and who are advising them and also
they're not their own content brad pitt
doesn't play brad pitt
he plays someone else right someone like
me my job is to edit myself
take my own photo make my own caption
reply to my own comments and it's all
like jim
jim jim jim it's very easy to then think
you're the center of the universe
but actually for every person who's
commenting going gym gym gym
they're also commenting on everybody
else's content because they just consume
the content
i might be their favorite i might not it
doesn't matter i'm not
um my i am not my job i think that's
really important for a lot of
influencers to work out like they
believe
themselves to be important
and actually i say this quite a lot if i
were to die tomorrow there'd be
my friends and family would be gutted
obviously and they'd be really really
sad and there'd be a few people in my
audience who were like
who um have a real connection with him
but for the most part people go oh
that's a shame i liked him and then move
on and find someone else i'm not
that important to them that they can't
continue without me so funny because
that
it sounds really depressive to somebody
to say i don't matter whatever but
i actually think it's the opposite
really freeing yeah it's the most
liberating thing ever i remember i
remember having the same sort of
existential conversation with myself and
it really happened when i learned about
the universe and space right and i got
really into the cosmos and i was like
wait a minute i'm [ __ ] not important
at all
totally like there's a scene in cosmos
where it zooms out from
and it just keeps going and you're like
wait stop and it's like nope that's just
the moon and then it goes out and it's
like that's just the galaxy
and then the galaxy becomes a piece of
sand and you're like what the
right but the freeing part is that means
that all this [ __ ] doesn't matter
and that's liberation like ego can be
and this is the the powerful thing about
psychedelics from
the last person that's out there who's
the biggest psychedelic investor in the
world right
is it dissolves your ego and says to you
nothing you don't [ __ ] matter right
and yeah i just thought that was
fascinating it's really something that's
really important to learn i think
probably one of my biggest
uh learnings from my career because i
went through it you know at the
beginning when everyone was like
obsessing over
the the youtubers i was like wow i'm
like a really big deal yeah
um i think it's really important to know
your worth and to know your value
and to um appreciate your position
i know that i am worth a certain amount
of money if i work with a brand or i
know that i'm worth
a certain amount of time if i'm doing a
thing but i also know that
i don't matter in the grand scheme of
things and that this is
a phase i might i might [ __ ] this up
tomorrow
do you know what i mean it might last
for another 10 years it might last for
another 30 years and i might never want
to quit
equally i might get bored of it and go
do you know what i feel like it's too
invasive now
whatever it doesn't matter it's my
decision and i don't owe anybody else
but equally they don't owe me they don't
have to watch me if they don't choose to
and i think that's really important a
lot of people especially when they're
young
and they're just developing their sense
of identity
as a lot of influences are and suddenly
i've put in a position where they are
reaching lots and lots of people
um it's very very easy to think of
yourself as the center of the galaxy
um we're not and actually what really
matters what truly matters
is the people that matter to you you
know
and as much as i appreciate my audience
i don't know
them you know i wouldn't no i mean
statistically there'll be a certain
number of them that die every year
just because of whatever right i've got
no idea it's happening
you're not sending cards you know what i
mean like i've got no idea it's
happening so
it just so happens that i'm on the other
side of the camera and these people
connect
to me and i connect to them but it
doesn't go any further than that you
know something really almost
something your perspective is
fascinating because on one end you're
very
you're very freed right on the other end
you talk about your anxiety of
of of worry and i'm trying to weigh
those two things up this idea that
you're like you know what
i don't have a plan i've heard you say
that i don't have a tenure plan the
future is the future whatever
but then maybe when we zoom in and we
look at the micro scale which is like
right now today
right it seems to be very yeah you know
you're not wrong i think on the
on the wider scale um i
um it's very freeing to know this on the
more individual scale like when you when
you zoom right in
it's the stress of survival i suppose of
like
um being enough to maintain
you know what that comes down to money i
think which is unfortunate because like
money is not my main motivator but i
realize it's necessary where did you
learn that i feel like there is
anything in your past where money or the
lack thereof beca
you know became um compromised your
safety
no i don't think compromise my safety
like i say we didn't have any
um and i appreciate that life is um
it's i like i said earlier there's a
point where
you have enough and that after that
point it doesn't matter anymore you know
you can go from having a little bit of
surplus so that you can
enjoy holidays et cetera you know buy
yourself some luxury things whatever you
want
after that point it's all numbers it
doesn't really make any difference
but when you go the other side of the
scale and you haven't got enough it's a
major stress
you know because what blows my mind
about it is it's all fake like it
doesn't
it's just it's literally me going hey
here's a piece of paper
for loads of your stuff and you go okay
cool i put value on that piece of paper
it's bollocks but it's unfortunately the
way our world works and that stresses me
out
just in terms of providing like
i couldn't go back i mean i could i'd
have to but
i would really struggle if i had to go
back to a conventional job
just doesn't suit me like i was bloody
miserable my mum thought i was going to
kill myself when i was working those
jobs you know i i
was very very sad
um i i think it's a it's a need for me
to create and i know that sounds really
ridiculous and really wank but
like i i can't
turn up to a job that is the same thing
every day
it it it for me feels like a prison um
and i actually i i think the people that
can do that are like special
because how wonderful to know that you
are um
you can switch on do your job um you can
know that you are
earning your money you're looking after
your people you know you raise your kids
whatever
whatever it is whatever your life is and
also provide to the society and give
back your taxes and all that stuff and
just be you know a good egg and then go
home and switch off again i just think
that's the most wonderful sensation
something i've never experienced and
probably never will because my mind
doesn't work that way
so for me my the anxiety comes from
the fear of going back to that
or not being able to provide and the
only way i know how to provide is
in a very risky industry where i
have to constantly churn out content
have to constantly create
whatever i'm creating in order to earn
the money um
and that's that's a scary thought yeah
um but i also appreciate that it's
it's the anxiety comes in the job of it
i think the freedom comes in the um
sort of the more i guess meta of it you
know like
i don't matter it does whatever the the
jim chapman's not really
of any relevance um but for my life
it's really important that i put food on
the table for sarah and my child
and that's funny because you know we
always live in now right right it's only
ever going to be now
yeah and uh what you're saying is in the
now there is urgency there is stress
yeah it's so we never we're never going
to live in the future it's never going
to be matter that's not the experience
we're ever going to have maybe if we
meditate we can spend some time there
but
day to day we live in the we live in the
present moment um
it's it's yeah it's really really
interesting to me and
as you say you're in an industry where
a lot of people aren't making a lot of
money right the creative industry so
it's yeah
particularly challenging um yeah very
much so and i think people are
following their passion i think the
thing with influencing in particular is
that the passion is
so easily monetized but it's also so
easy taken away and it's so competitive
that it often
i think some people are just passionate
about the business of it
um now i don't pretend to have a
business mind at all i haven't got a
bloody clue like i've got
a production company that i've just
started with one of my pals and he is in
charge of the business
when it comes to my my social media
stuff my management are in charge of the
business
i just make the stuff i want to make and
stuff that i think will be good
um and i fully believe in letting people
do play to their strengths my strength
is not that so
i often get called like an entrepreneur
or something i'm like you know all right
i just i it's just been it's been
luck and timing and really bloody hard
work um
and the hard work i can i'm in control
of the luck and the timing i'm not
um and the other people around me
are in charge of sort of i guess
bringing looking after like the
financial side of it and stuff you know
it's the admin stuff that
i don't you hate i hate the fiery
passion
yeah i hate it you said just a couple of
moments ago
the proponents that have made you
successful you said like you know luck
hard work etc etc
do you think you could have achieved
what you've achieved over the last 10
years
without hard work no absolutely not
how would you square that with the
culture we live in today
that is almost viewing hard work as a
bit of a toxic thing
i've almost got to the point i'll never
get there because i don't care that much
but i've almost got to the point just to
say again i will never get there right
because i'm not gonna lie to people
where i sometimes feel bad being honest
that i wouldn't be here without hard
work
i'm not telling you to burn out right
but i don't know how
if i hadn't have sacrifice in the way
that i did i would of course that's my
experience
i've not lived another life right i can
only tell you what i've done yeah
i think it's really important it's like
work hard play hard right
it's really important i i i posted this
on on my instagram stories other days
everybody there's like you're right
there is a lot of people who are sort of
um
[Music]
uh poo pooing working hard don't work
too hard and there's also people who
like
on my instagram it comes up all the time
hey i run three businesses and i do this
and i'm only
12 years old and like yeah but that
guy's trying to sell you a course
for sure he's his business yes for sure
that's what i mean he's broke there's
there's
there's there's definitely something to
be said and this is where i like again
like
this is where i struggle when you work
work hard like and work with passion
like you know again sarah's dad says um
work is a dirty four-letter word
right you if you find the other saying
if you find something you love doing
you'll never work a day in your life so
work
really hard and work with passion but
also
stop when you need to stop take your
time off enjoy your evenings or
you know again i've got a job which
allows me to work as much as little as i
please i wish i did like a four day week
i would very much like to do that so i
have a three day weekend or i take a day
off in the middle of the week i've got
the means to do so just i've got the
brain to do so you know
um and i think that
that's a really important distinction
otherwise you work all your bloody life
and suddenly you're 60
and you've gone oh my god i haven't i
actually enjoyed my experiences
um i haven't actually you know i've got
to do some really bloody incredible
experiences and sometimes i'm too busy
stressing about
what's next in my diary or finishing a
thing meeting a deadline
or even stressing about the key messages
i've got to get across when i'm on that
adventure that i forget to
enjoy the adventure and it's the biggest
sort of um waste of time that my job
has within it you know like i remember
being in a
on a helicopter and this wasn't me
actually this was somebody else who who
i recognized in
i was taken away um to new york i was
going on a helicopter around manhattan
and it was like you know what a cool
experience and people don't get to do
that very often
um and this guy was sat next to me in
the middle and he couldn't
take his picture because he had to lean
over me and i said i'll swap seats with
you
the pilot came over the um you know the
whatever it said
and said um oh don't swap seats because
you'll unbalance the helicopter the guy
was so pissed off and now i want to swap
i'm like well no because you'll kill us
now so
it's a bit different i offered you my
seat when i didn't think we were going
to die
um for doing and he sold so much because
he couldn't get the photo he wanted and
i'm like
that for me really really kind of is the
epitome of
not enjoying the moment like just enjoy
the bloody helicopter ride around
manhattan you idiot
um but that's probably byproduct of
social media or something because
yeah you know the part of the value of
that was for him clearly was being able
to tell the world he did it versus
being in the moment for sure for sure
and that and unfortunately that is
job we have to tell a while we've done
something otherwise
you know it hasn't happened right and
then there's no point taking
me on that really cool experience
because i haven't told anyone about it
you know so that there's definitely a a
dichotomy there
in that you need to prove that you've
done it and you need to
show your enjoyment um but you need to
also not let that take you out of the
moment and that's a fine line
one of the things i've been thinking a
lot about lately which links to that
completely
is because i sit here with people all
the time and i and one of the things i
keep noticing is that
in order for them to actually be happy
they have to try and be a contradiction
or two completely different people in
separate areas of their life and right a
lot of the the lack of success they have
either in their work or relationships or
whatever
or in their personal lives comes from
them not being able to
switch off from being from going like
being
super successful entrepreneur and then
when they get home being loving patient
right you know and then in the example
we've just been talking about there
i would assume happiness would come from
being able to do your job and take the
photo
but then have experiences where you just
don't give a [ __ ] if the world is
watching that's entirely it like how do
that's not easy no it's not easy i
um and dare i say the thing that put you
on the helicopter
might have been the inability to switch
off in some degree
because it's absolutely hard work i
haven't i haven't got to where i am
by switching off whenever i choose to
you know what i mean i've got here
because i work
harder than i should um that's that's a
massive sacrifice because i've missed
out on moments
i've missed out on um you know
like there are times where i should just
be more present with sarah but i'm too
busy working you know i miss out on
things but
i get to go on a helicopter but you know
more than that i get to live a really
cool existence like i love my job
so it's really difficult but my the way
i kind of
cross that tee dot that i i suppose is
that
i will very often much rather pay for a
holiday
and have a actual holiday yeah rather
than just calling a trip
yeah it's very easy i mean i you know
without sounding like a real [ __ ] it's
very easy for me to call tripping if i
want to yeah
i just email a pr say oh i want to go to
dubai
and they'll go all right when you want
to go right but i tend not to
because i listen if it is oftentimes
a thing will come to me and it's a place
i've never been or experienced i've
never had and i'll jump on it
but i will tend not to request a free
trip
because honestly my time is more
valuable than the money i can
potentially earn so i would rather
pay my money to go somewhere
and switch off and read a book do the
crossword puzzle
hang out you know because i value that
much more than the money
i think that that's the thing i think
some people
put their value in money in my view too
high um
and i i don't value it like that i think
my
what's most important what i value more
is people and time
okay quick one quick story from one of
my podcast sponsors fiverr fiverr.com is
a lot of you all know if you've listened
to this podcast before
um one of the challenges we've had with
this podcast over the last i'd say a
couple of months since we've really
cranked up the production
is we usually promote the podcast just
on mondays so you've probably seen on my
channels monday morning about 9am
i put the podcast out there and one of
the things we've wanted to do
is to keep that sort of momentum and
height moving throughout the week from
monday
till sunday when the next podcast comes
out but we've had a bit of a resource
capacity because jack who
produces all of this and edits all of
this only has so much time and these
podcasts are coming in thick and fast so
we turn to fiverr to help us extend our
capacity
and we hired a video editor on fiverr
who's now producing all of our video
clips for this podcast
so now in a very very very cost
effective way we've been able to promote
the podcast every single day from monday
till sunday
that is what five is all about extending
your team giving you capabilities you
might not have had
and doing it in a very cost effective
way
one of the other really interesting
things you said as we were talking maybe
before we started filming was
you were talking about the things that
you're good at writing about with your
screenplays and one of the things you
said was love
yeah i thought to myself i wonder why
he's good at writing about love
um i don't know actually i i
i know my strengths when it comes to
writing and it's one of those things
where to begin with vulgar imposter
syndrome right constantly i still got it
10 years on but i know
i'm good at that um i know i can send a
script somewhere they might not like it
it might not be the thing for them and i
get told no quite a lot but invariably
they say you know what
great script you've done a really good
job there so i
am confident in my ability there and i
know my strengths
are dialogue um because i write
how people talk but also get the point
across like i can't
i'm the worst person to watch to film
with because if i'm watching something
i'm like people don't talk like
that what is going you know um but also
love
i i just think i've got i i don't know i
think i'm a bit of an old romantic and
it comes down
i think it really for me comes down to
how you feel love
you know if you can feel love and you
can put pen to paper you can write love
um
and i i i
pride myself on trusting and loving
like to i'm not a jealous person i'm not
um i'm never gonna micromanage a
relationship or anything like that
if i love someone i trust them
implicitly they can do as they wish they
can go out with the boys
or whatever i'm never gonna go oh who
did you meet and what happened i'm never
gonna like check their phone
sure you know i'm never gonna do any of
that because if i love someone i'm all
in
um and that for me is really important
if you get your fingers burned then all
right then you then that's they get one
chance
you know um that's that's my life you
had a very public relationship
one that was shared on youtube for many
many years you ended up marrying
said person and um and then that
relationship ended yeah um
difficult i imagine to to have that
experience in public right it's too
impossible yeah like it's uh you know we
were together for 12 years and
most of that time was wonderful you know
it was really
great like i said we conquered the world
together we were both part of that first
breed of
influences social media people we had a
wicked time and then we grew up together
it was as simple as growing up in
slightly different directions you know
um and at some point you know are you
going to do the
further you go on yeah like that why did
the gap get i literally just did this
for the first time last week on this
podcast i was like
i'm almost starting to see relationships
like two parallel lines yeah
and and if you imagine the parallel
lines have just a one
percent angle either way sure right
they're either going to stay parallel
they're
going to go away from each other or
closer together over time totally i look
back at it now and i realized that
actually
it probably it was a small a small
incline or decline whichever you want to
put it but it
at some point becomes insurmountable
becomes a chasm you can't leap anymore
right so
i look back at it and realize that
perhaps it was uh it started much
earlier than
either of us anticipated even either of
us realized and we just kind of kept
getting more and more distant until
eventually we
were just roommates basically um
was it hard to break it off when you get
to that point because you've got the
world watching
yeah it wasn't hard as a couple because
we were both
we both knew we deserved better right we
both knew we're like
this isn't working and we took a it took
a long time to have the conversation
because i think we both tried
for a while we're like oh come back
around we'll come back around but we
we're not stupid we both knew we
deserved better
so the com when we actually had the
conversation it was for both of us quite
freeing emotional because of all the
time we had together but
quite freeing of course you then got
the audience to think of who make
assumptions
right and oh i've lost countless amount
of times i've been called a cheater
um just and poor old sarah gets called
my mistress constantly
i just i didn't even know sarah existed
like she was not
a person to me until well after we broke
up you know like i met her on an app
and like i'm really i'm really tempted
at some point sometimes to
get the app right i haven't got it
anymore but i want to re-download it and
find our conversation
look we started talking on this date um
just just to prove the point because
it's not
sarah didn't sign up for this [ __ ] you
know she fell in love with me
um and it just so happens that i come
with a bit of
an audience who have opinions on things
and you know we all gossip right
we've all got opinions on things that i
watch people go through breaks up
breakups on tv
or i watch like the drama with say megan
and harry or whatever and
i have my thoughts and my feelings on it
um but of course i'm not gonna
dm them about it you know um
and i think that is the issue that on
the internet there's a sort of anonymity
an anonymity and people can
say things thinking there's no
repercussions i lost my [ __ ] the other
day on social media because
and i'd never address it i very much of
the
like i said earlier i'm inconsequential
on the ground scheme of things so i can
take hate i've got a thick skin it
doesn't it bounces straight off i don't
care
like this this is my job it's not a
personal reflection on me so whatever
but somebody had dm'd sarah a bunch of
pictures of my old relationship my
previous life and said you'll never
match up to her
and then has sent another one saying and
your child deserves to be miscarried
and i lost my [ __ ] and i've never
i've never behaved this way online but i
went straight to my instagram stories
and i told the person
i said [ __ ] you to the person um
and also i was very mad and perhaps i
should have let cooler heads prevail but
actually the amount of
um support i had off the back of it
people saying you know what bloody too
right stand up for
you stand up for sarah stand up for
yourself stand up for your child
um and i've we've had two years of it
right because
me and tony broke up just over two years
ago me and sarah got together
i don't know like as far as the world is
concerned a few months later but
obviously that wasn't it because the
world only found out
me and tony broke up when we decided to
tell them we decided to tell them when
we did because the press found out
so actually it was much earlier than
anyone realizes because we were trying
to
get our heads around it and work out how
to do it with minimal
um sort of like minimal backlash minimum
negative energy
negative energy right because we didn't
have any towards each other at all
um but when it comes to
when it comes to me being called a
cheater or whatever whatever it's fine
it bounces back off and
i hold my head high everybody who i know
and care about and respect and love
knows
what really happened and that's what
really matters to me i don't care but
when it comes to somebody
calling my pregnant fiance the names
they called her and saying that my baby
should be miscarried that's where i draw
the line
the person that sent that message
you know that they they probably wanted
that reaction
yeah i do um i one of the best pieces of
advice
that i was ever given was don't play
around
in the mud with the picks because you
both get dirty but the pigs will love it
right
so i live by a motto i've never
explained never complain
i don't i own my decisions like i own my
life
i'm an adult i don't have to explain
myself to anyone
should i not wish to right simple um
i am confident
in my ability and my decisions that
i'm like this is the path i'm choosing
and you can
like it or lump it basically um
but i felt like making an example i
didn't out anyone i didn't say any names
i didn't you know share any
usernames but i felt like making an
example of that person
especially with it being so out of
character for me to do so would have had
overall a positive consequence for the
people who were thinking it but weren't
writing it or the people that were
thinking of writing it
and actually do you know what sarah is
getting much less of it now i'm getting
much less of it now
um so i think in a way it was almost
like cost-benefit analysis
yeah in a way you know i i weigh these
things up and i think there's
always going to i've been thinking a lot
lately because of um there was a couple
of my friend is the global head of
social media at manchester united right
and there's a lot of black players
right and so when the team loses what
you see on the black players instagram
there's lots of monkey emojis
and um it's actually awfully
my friend called me said what do we do
about this right he said
we're gonna take this dance um as a club
and you know they
we talked a little bit about it on like
a whatsapp group or whatever and the
club
stood up changed the cover photos and
said like manchester united against
races and the players got more racism
because shining a light on it yeah it's
like it's almost like it's not a real
thing
how do i explain this it's it could be
some 14 year old kid
who who's leaving these monkey emojis
who is actually
quite an okay person but they just have
this thing in them where they want a bit
of attention right they see
you or marcus rashford is not really a
real human
right and an idol and so they think just
leaving they're not like an inherently
bad person but when you get anonymity
and you get and we all have this you
know envy in us that comes from
somewhere you know the lifeboat analogy
right
and so like i i'm what i'm i don't know
what i'm basically saying is like
i don't think we're ever going to be
able to cure that problem
with the only way i've actually seen is
i think you'd kill 99
of it if social networks weren't
anonymous and you had to upload your
passport
because i think if you connect real
world consequences to behavior i fully
agree it's why you don't get your dick
out in public it's like
well that's not why but it's like that's
the only reason it's why you don't go up
to someone and say those things in
public
because there's a real world consequence
totally agree i think i think people
should
have there should be some sort of like
identification process when you set up
an account i totally agree with it
because
the amount i get the amount sarah gets
um
is it's a real bloody shame as well
because especially because these people
are like
supposed to be and i use this in
inverted commas fans they're supposed to
care about my life my existence they're
supposed to you know they followed me
for a reason
yeah um and i refuse to believe
especially because i'm i like to think
i'm a force of positivity
i tend i talk real talk and i share real
things but
even when i'm talking about mental
health or a bigger issue i do so from a
stance of positivity right
at least i try to so i refuse to believe
that somebody is that
negative or hates me that much but in
six mil you've got i know six how many
followers you got
uh uh across everything i don't think
i've got
two on youtube two on insta
just over two on twitter i don't i don't
know about facebook yeah
six seven eight whatever but then you're
reaching more people you know
the people that follow you aren't the
ones that you're reached yeah of course
if you took that many people
and thought probabilistically
how many of them would just not be like
okay people but have the
capability of sending an awful lot yeah
there's going to be a [ __ ]
thousands yeah you also guarantee that
when i do like for example when i
announced that sarah and i were pregnant
um i
went on to twitter and i was i was
trending and i haven't tried it for
years i was like oh this is fun
for so long so i was going through it
and 99
it was really positive but there was a
lot of it that was just like um
you know a little bit of hate and i had
a really good time responding to some of
it
not like i wasn't saying anything like
for example someone was like
jim chapman still exists and he's not
with tanya and he's having a baby who
knew
um and i just retweeted him responding i
know right what turned up for the books
i am i'm still alive
so nothing like i didn't respond to real
negativity
just people going wow that's like that's
a funny old story oh it's not tanya
um and like i really enjoyed
i i i actually found that good fun
because
by drawing attention to it these people
were then like oh my god i love you
you're the best
because obviously i've let them know
that i've seen it and that i'm not
tolerating [ __ ]
but also i don't care enough that i'm
going to write something really negative
back i'm just
like yeah i see that i acknowledge it i
am here i'm also a human
and it's yeah it's a really interesting
sort of phenomenon that people
can write what they want without any
sort of consequences but when you give
them consequences
they'll suddenly be like oh wow you've
noticed me i'm a really funny
funny thing that happened this week this
weekend yesterday
um there's a story that came out in the
press something that i had done this kid
had like dm to me if he'd made me a
wikipedia page and was like i thought
you deserve one so i made one and i
offered him a job in 10 minutes
i said what a great show of initiative
you've shown your writing skills like
come work with us
it was in the papers there's this like
facebook page where one of the articles
in the papers was posted
there's 60 comments 59 of them are like
amazing right
and then there's this one comment which
is like
really [ __ ] it's like steve bartlett
is like an evil guy he
they said that i made a pr story out of
the manchester bombings because we
raised a huge amount we let our team
have the day off
right and we and we raised this huge
amount of money for the families of the
victims right
and so he wrote all this awful stuff
about me and
i screenshotted it and i i messaged the
guy and i said could you like i sent him
the screenshot i mean could you explain
this
i've never seen someone just completely
changed
and i said and one of the things i said
to him was would you would you be okay
with me sharing this on my channels
guess what he said well obviously not
absolutely not
and i was never going to share my
channels right but i said why wouldn't
why can't i share in public
well because he's written on a public
forum right he's written on a public
forum
why can't i share on my channel why
wouldn't you like three million people
seeing that
right and and he was like he literally i
went do i have your permission to share
this and he went
absolutely not yeah i was like do i have
you permission to respond to it publicly
absolutely not and it was just
fascinating to see the behavior because
he obviously ate was in some facebook
group
didn't expect me to see it you know and
this is i'm trying to over the last
couple of
i guess months trying to understand how
to deal
with this social media centric
often group think driven because i'm
sure all the cheating stuff was
one oh yeah yeah there's a group of
people and then they're like yeah
yeah i would say tanya's never said
anything um she's never come out and
called me a cheetah
um she hasn't done the opposite um like
i have if i'm being totally frank about
it like you know
i've sort of said there was nothing
you've addressed it i've addressed it
i'm trying to
i moved on first sure as far as
the world is concerned you know what i
mean like
it's really hard to say this without
sort of making
accusations whatever as far as the world
knows
i moved on first it's not necessarily
i should stop there but it's
it's tricky to be accused of something
when
they've only got limited information to
to use right so
because people see that i moved on first
they
think that perhaps i cheated so for me
saying
i didn't cheat and for sarah's saying i
didn't cheat with jim
um it doesn't necessarily prove anything
right because
of course we're going to say that
because we want to deny our
infidelity right um
and it's tricky to keep going back to
and keep saying the same thing
especially when it's so unfounded
um but there's a point you just have to
let it go right you can't you can't
change everyone's opinion about it like
i said like there's
there's like a a load of people
watching you they all have opinions on
you good or bad and
the perks of this job is that we get
paid well for it and that we get to
live a bloody adventure like it's so
cool i never expected this for my life i
never expected to be able to do the
stuff i get to do and
live the life i get to live it was never
planned out for me i never had like
um the tools in place for it i found
myself here and i've
grabbed on with both hands and i've
worked really hard to to
maintain it so that's the perk of being
in a position i'm in unfortunately it
comes with a few drawbacks
which is that people make opinions on
you and
you just have to not care so much not
easy though it's not easy at all
especially when they message your fiance
it's not easy at all especially
also when it's so
untrue um
and yeah and and also there's no way to
rectify it
there's no way there's no way i can
rectify it or sarah basically
yeah um that's difficult that's really
difficult it is very difficult
yeah yeah and and you must have this you
would see these falsehoods in the
comment sections you must
instinctively be like oh that's not true
and that's harmful to my relationships
or whatever
i need to fix that and i still really
value tanya we're still
we're still mates so i'm not
you know i'm never gonna i'm not gonna
uh make a big
thing i try to just when it comes up in
conversation i'll just say
yeah it's this we grew apart right
because i respect her and i value her
and i i'm
i don't want to keep bringing up all the
time because also it doesn't define
either of us
people break up all the time
unfortunately they don't always break up
in public but it doesn't define us we
both still have our careers we both
still have our lives we both still have
our people
um and that's very important it's just a
shame that
it comes up so frequently and it's so um
untrue
i had a sex therapist a relationship
therapist
on this podcast um two weeks ago and she
said a really lovely sentence which i
haven't been able to forget
and she said just because a relationship
ends doesn't mean it wasn't successful
i still look at us as very successful
yeah like i said we
ticked all our boxes the next thing for
us was what i'm now doing with sarah and
um i see now that tanya would not be the
person to do that with
you know and sarah a hundred percent is
and
there are things that i have with her
that i've never experienced before um
and i'm very lucky like i said earlier i
feel like when
when tanya and i started going sep
directions separate ways
um it was earlier than i
i think either of us kind of gave
credence to um
and so if we had i've done if you know
if i have done the things i'm now doing
with sarah with tony i
don't think it would have been for the
best
you know whereas now i'm i know that
sarah's my person i've learned a lot i
know what i'm worth i know what
i can expect from a partner um
and it's it's really i've never
experienced it this way it's really
lovely it's really fruitful it's really
rewarding it's really
dynamic and it's really reciprocal did
you have a list of
um attributes i was talking to a couple
of friends the other day um
mixgender group and one of them posed
the question like what's on your list
for an ideal partner
um so you're with the partner so i'm
saying i guess my question to you is
what does what did you look for but and
also i want you to answer the second
question which is
what does a partner need to offer jim in
order to be a good partner
uh okay well partly to offer me i think
um
i i need to like i said earlier if i if
i love someone i trust them 100
right i expect the same in return i
can't deal with
jealousy i can't deal with someone
checking up on me if i'm
out or if i'm doing something
i'm not gonna humor it because it's not
me
and i don't want anyone to consider that
it might be me and if if
as my partner you're thinking oh he's
out somewhere he's
with someone doing something he
shouldn't be then i haven't got time for
it so
i expect that um but also i
i expect to be
appreciated and reciprocated um you know
i know it's complicated it doesn't
happen all the time there are times when
you're in a bad mood or whatever but
as i was walking here sarah texts me
saying i know i haven't said it at
lowe's because um
i'm just feeling really sick you know
with the pregnancy and everything but
she went
my my baby is jackpot with a dad you
know and like i just want you to know i
really do appreciate you
um and i haven't said it much lately and
that's that's that's all i need
why does that matter to you so much
because i i want to know that i'm valued
um and that's that's that's the thing
for me i don't care
why um
because if i'm going to give someone my
all and like i said earlier if i'm in
love with someone they get everything
they get all my stuff if it's stuff i
care about i get all my time they get
everything right
um and i need to know that there's value
in me giving myself does that link to
your childhood
at all perhaps yeah perhaps i i just
fully believe and maybe this is why i
write love well i fully believe that if
i'm with someone
they've got it all right i don't believe
in i don't mean that in like a really um
codependent way
because that's like the worst you know
if you're kind of encouraging each other
into
something i feel like you both need to
live your life independently but make a
good team
and like you when you team up together i
think good stuff happens basically
um and yeah perhaps but but i
i think that i
for me if i'm not
if i don't feel like i'm valued enough i
don't feel like
my um it's not i say sacrifice it's not
a sacrifice but if i don't feel like
what i'm giving isn't
appreciated or but my worst nightmare
is being tolerated like i'm with someone
and they just go yeah all right and they
just they just tolerate me i'm out the
door
um because i'm too good for that
like i i have value and everybody does
i'm not saying me is an
individual each and every single person
has their value right they deserve to be
appreciated for that value and if
they're with someone who doesn't
appreciate it
takes it for granted um whatever
then you're not with the right person
you know i think the you you need
someone who
uh respects you and appreciates you um
and who
sees your worth perhaps more than you do
i mean i
i don't see myself that clearly
sometimes
um and sarah will often often say like
you know the text she sent me
saying you know my my babies at the
jackpot with the dad that
they've got coming up is you know this
that means a lot to me
i've had a chance to reply yet but i
will after this and that is it's a
really big
thing it doesn't it's so such little
effort for her to send but it means a
[ __ ] lot to me have you heard about love
languages
yeah have you ever done the old love
language test no have you ever
you know i tend not to not i don't
believe in that stuff i just tend not to
um i think ignorance is bliss sometimes
because if i'm super aware of it then i
don't know if it's
like i said earlier with the therapy
right when you're aware of your
your thing your stuff yeah and then you
do it more like ah
and until you learn the tools of how to
overcome it or how to at least challenge
it
it's frustrating and i feel like if i
learned that i was this
way inclined every time i did i'd go
[ __ ] call me apparently i'm apparently
i'm like
the archetypal capricorn you want to do
your love languages now go on shall we
yeah i did mine and it's actually really
you know i'm not that guy i'm not like a
i'm not i don't look at this the sun and
decide what's going to happen tomorrow
because of
where the planets are i'm not that guy
but the the love language thing
is based on asking you a bunch of
questions about like what you value more
so ultimately comes up with an answer
and it says jim chapman values
when someone does this and yours would
be words of affirmation or recognition
mine is slightly different so we'll talk
about mine but interesting um we're
going to do your love language now this
is going to drive me mental for the rest
of my life now
like i said like apparently i am the
most archetypal capricorn and every time
i do anything that's sort of capricorny
now and i never really believed in this
sort of stuff
every time i do anything now i'm like
damn it my bloody stars told me
or something okay here we go okay so me
and jim have just completed the full
love language survey which took um about
10 minutes
and his results why am i nervous i know
everything about you and i'm looking at
all of your results yeah
um so it says and this is not surprising
this is what i expected from our
conversation up until that point right
jim's primary love language is words of
affirmation right
actions don't always speak louder than
words if this is your love language
unsolicited compliments mean the world
to you hearing the words i love you are
important hearing the reasons behind
that loves
um sends your spirits skyward insults
can leave you shattered and are not
easily forgotten
kind encouraging and supportive words
are truly
life-giving to you and you rank as a 33
percent
on words of affirmation which is high
you rank as three percent on receiving
gifts
17 on acts of service and then physical
and
physical touch and quality time you rank
the same okay
i would say gifts i i think it might be
more to somebody else
i think that my job comes with a lot of
stuff yeah so i don't really care about
it so much
um i'd agree with that um like i said
earlier we get lots of hate and it
bounces off but if the hate comes from
someone i love yeah that's an issue yeah
if it's an insult as well an insult yeah
yeah
yeah
that's that's a problem if it comes from
someone um that i care about
um yeah you know what i'm really lucky
cause sarah does all of that she
actually does most of everything
um which is great um and
um genuinely i'm very fortunate to have
her um
she is everything that i
want and i use the word want and not
need because i think that's the
difference between
codependency and like a healthy
relationship i don't need her i would be
fine my life would continue
but she brings a little uh a little
spice a little something extra you know
what i mean
and and it's much more enjoyable to have
her by my side for everything
for sure so what's next for you then
you're working on a lot we were talking
about this software yeah i am
um i'm always working on on stuff like i
said
just i just love creating um so i
have just started a production company
with my friend we started in january
or february last year so just as the
world might explode but actually you
know what has given us the chance to
really knuckle down
um and we've got some really good
headway so far um
we're having lots of big conversations
with important people and people seem to
like our stuff
um i we do scripted and unscripted so i
head up the unscripted
sorry i have the scripted stuff so my
writing so far i've got a couple of
films on the go
writing a book um i'm also working on a
like a
a show like a series and we've got a
bunch of unscripted
stuff that i also chip in on um but
that's very much
james my my business partner is very
much his sort of um
wheelhouse um and the difference in time
it will take so he's constantly having
meetings and constantly like churning
stuff out whereas my stuff takes a lot
longer
so i often feel like i'm not pulling my
weight but then i'll send him like i
just sent him a document yesterday which
is 20 000 words long which took me two
weeks to write and it's like a
an entire breakdown beat by beat of how
i see this new thing working
and he's like oh so you're doing stuff
so it's it's weird but i think um we
both
we both are really invested we're both
really good at what we do we're
successful in our own rights
um but i think there's something special
about working on something that's just
for passion we don't need this to work
we just really really want it to and
that's
really exciting you know if they say oh
you know jim chapman was a success 10
years from now what would they mean
um what would that mean to you i mean
for me
if i were saying about myself it would
it would mean that i
in terms of work it would mean that i
was respected in my field
um it would mean people who my
contemporaries appreciated my input
but more than that if it were just in
general success it would mean i got out
okay you know what i mean i came out the
other side of this and
um i
have i'm content for me contentment is
sort of like a
a goal you know and i don't think it is
for many people
um i don't want to stress about stuff
unnecessarily i don't
want to constantly strive for more um i
don't feel like
it's necessary i want to be really happy
with what i've got and i have that
very in spades with my people my family
my friends um sarah my baby on the way
i've got more contentment than i can
throw a stick at i don't have it in
terms of
my career because i'm constantly worried
about
where it goes so have you ever i hope i
do i hope i
i think what what it would take is um a
project
that is very successful so with my
writing and then people come to me
rather than me constantly knocking on
flies you know what i mean it'd be
really nice to be in a position where go
hey you wrote that thing and it did
really well i want to give you
opportunities now rather than me chasing
it and i have that in terms of social
media like
i'm very lucky to be in the position i'm
in which is sort of i've been doing it
for a very long time and have a good
name for myself so people often come to
me
i don't have it in my the other part of
my job and i'd love that but i'm still
doing it i've only been doing it you
know like i say i've been
writing the first screenplay for three
and a half years but that only got to a
point where it was
worth talking about a year ago you know
so it's still very much in its infancy
so i just hope that i get to a point
where
people um like my stuff and go you know
what you're really good at this let's
let's work with you on this project
if it doesn't happen it won't be through
lack of trying um and i won't hold it
against myself i'm not gonna be
i won't feel like a failure um because i
don't
i don't really believe in that i i
believe you can be a failure if you
quit and you never try you never try
it's all right but
if you don't make it and you and you've
given it a good bloody shot then
you know you've done better than most
yeah i said that tweet the other day and
i was in the gym and i thought about it
i thought you know
the concept of worry and fear are so
illogical because you know no human has
ever done more than their best right and
even on my [ __ ] days where i'm like
really unproductive and whatever bad
mood or whatever
that was actually still my best that day
yeah
by definition so this you know um but
it's fascinating and i
um i looking over your story in your
career one of the
the key things i saw was this temptation
from you to like resist your labels
and to and to not be sucked into the
world
telling you who you are yeah i i i think
it doesn't really
you know what it's one of those things
where you meet people and the second
question they ask you is what you do for
a living the first being hi
what's your name right and there's more
to all of us than
what we do like i said earlier my job
isn't what what my job is what i do not
who i am right so
i don't like being jim chapman youtuber
you know um stifling it's like a boxer
it's totally a box and in the same way
the same way that you know an accountant
might not want to just be called
an accountant you know there's more to
him he's got his own life and
whatever um i just feel like it's
it's pigeonholing and it's tricky in
this industry because
people don't like you being good at more
than one thing if you're written about
um in the press or whatever it's
probably for you entrepreneur i'd
imagine right
for me it's youtuber still um and
actually like i say that's a small part
of i upload
one video a week and i've only been
doing that since we found out we were
pregnant because now it's exciting to
talk about stuff yeah other than that i
haven't uploaded for six months
you know what i mean so there's more to
us we're allowed
to explore new avenues do new things but
i think for the sake of um society
understanding who which box you fit in
right
because in articles they have to use a
word right so that the reader knows
and they can't say jim chapman and then
list your your skills
yeah yeah so they're like box which box
right and i understand it because it's
it's how we even down to like you know
the
a simple individual level we all
stereotype yeah because
yeah i mean that's just that's just
psychologically it makes sense
because totally and it gives us sort of
like categories to work from
if you're walking down the street and
you see every single person as an
individual
it's sensory overload so you see someone
in say a certain
clothing and a suit you know okay you're
a banker he might not be you might just
like wearing a suit but
in your head that's what he's done
because it's easier just to sort of
carry on with your day compartmentalise
imagine if we didn't imagine if
you know lion running towards us we
thought i wonder if this is a good lion
generally i said this to sarah just the
other day we're having a conversation
quite a heated conversation about
something and um she's
i call her worst case scenario sarah
quite a lot because she often will
catastrophize right and i said you're
the kind of person that sees someone
running
and you assume they're running from i
don't know a crime
or a gun or something i'm the kind of
person that assumes they're running
towards a bus
because i i i see the world as
neutral right i don't think the world
has an opinion on me um
but i see my people as positive and i
know there's lots of negativity out
there but
um i don't see the world as that kind of
place in general whereas some people i
think are geared up
to think the worst it's like um you know
the whole fight and flight thing
um some people are geared i think i
think i'd probably die right because i'd
be geared up to see a stick
as a stick whereas actually it makes
much more sense to see a stick as a
snake
because on the one time it is a snake
you don't die yeah whereas oh it's a
stick and i get bitten and die
um so i think uh if it were 200 000
years ago i would be no good but
actually in today's society i do all
right because i just like to
see i think inherently i just see the
world as a
neutral or or at best positive um
i don't want to think that everybody
running is running from an explosion
you know it's just not the way i choose
to see the world
i think that's a much healthier way to
see the world like to think so we could
take you much further
but anyway listen thank you so much for
your time today i think you're an
incredibly
inspiring guy not least because of what
you've achieved but because of your
willingness to be honest
thank you i think you know a lot of the
stuff you've shared about your childhood
and
being open as a man about you you know
the impact therapy has had on you i
think is such an admirable thing and
even your call to you know to men to go
to therapy i think is something that i
can
completely get behind right um there's
been so much stigma around it
for you know you know a bunch of
historical reasons right
as a society were overcoming but i but i
really applaud you for that and
i'm super excited to see what you do
next you know you're clearly someone
that's
a brilliantly talented be it's
incredibly hard working
and um yeah and that that mixed with
your your um
so that your huge amount of
self-awareness i think is going to make
for some unbelievable
i i hope so i also think that it could
go
totally the opposite way but either way
you know i i will i know
whatever i do i'll do to the rest of my
ability you know so
if it doesn't go the way i intend i'll
find the next thing you know
i'm smart enough to do that thank you
[Music]